the ladies all got together for a candid
chat about parenting and oh yeah well
they also talk about the men they share
their lives with as you made this movie
really like honey
I hope you're watching this to any of
your husbands I haven't really great
husband I really did wrong I know when I
did you like hey there hasn't been
enough time for me to be like pay
attention like he's still like he's
still super present and we only have a
21 month old this were very new at this
well Milla and practically perfect how
the Ashton Kutcher are expecting baby
number two but the truth about
motherhood it's a tough job and these
famous ladies got very candid about it
and her mom summit what was it like the
first time post-chat children you got to
go out and really like kick it with your
girls it was great and then I was
exhausted my husband and I went to he
took me to the Cure concert for my
birthday
right after my daughter was born and um
we fell asleep
I'll totally get a sitter on a Tuesday
night the struggle is real but the bad
bombs in the movie go where most of us
only ever dream to there are so many
tools now don't punish your kids don't
say no to your kid how do you balance
all this craziness it's never gonna be
perfect done you don't beat yourself up
almost feel you've chosen wrong that's a
key part of it I'm so tired of trying to
be this perfect mom done I would say
just the mere aspect of having so much
pressure that you put on yourself and
constantly you disappointed in your own
self is something that I have to deal
with very early on is also something
that like I battle with my daughter all
the time like how do you raise a kid in
today's society that's not making out to
be one other thing I did not know that
mom still do like the hot dad's out
there does that really happen we had
kids were not dead yeah I love that
response we're not dead look at the hot
dog good
you